how does a writer become more self-aware
if they don't have representation they
don't have anybody
yet in their camp they're new but they
want to learn
what mistakes are they making is from
something as simple as even going into
pitch something
and how they're presenting themselves
well the thing is uh first of all
there's there's the script element right
so
you want to expose the work early and
often to people that you can trust or
that
there is no no negative impact if they
don't like the work so
readers consultants you want to get
feedback from people in the know
writers groups other writers that you
respect um
your mother your best friend your
husband your wife your kid
love them they don't count unless they
are you know
kelly masterson who just wrote snow
pierce or sure if you're if you're
married to kelly masterson
go get his two cents and by all means
but short of that
you want to find on the script front
first of all you want to find people
that will give you script feedback that
is knowledgeable and seasoned
so it's not it can't be just anybody i
don't like
notes from anonymous sources because if
i don't know who's giving the nouns how
do i know to trust the notes
um you know and then when it comes to
things like this like story expo pitch
events
you want to walk in prepped um i can
tell you that for example for me i do
preps with my writers i did
i did eight sessions of prep with one
writer for one event
going over the pitch going over the one
sheet making sure that it's coming off
the right way
making sure i'm getting no distractions
um that same writer went to writer
friends to writers who are
show show runners who become show
runners writers who are writing in rooms
and ran the pitch by them to really
prepare and practice
there are a lot of people that walk into
pitch event and think oh i can just wing
it the reality is that in today's world
there's enough resources out there to
not have to wing it
you can walk in prepared so whether you
work with somebody like me or somebody
like stephanie palmer
who works on pitching or you know read
michael hague selling your script in 60
seconds you have some starting points
to really start planning and preparing
because ultimately
luck favors the prepared
you